hello my name is potato gum and I'm a
orchestra conductor and musician and I'd
like to say something concerning Brian
McKeon's question about interesting idea
the most interesting idea i had today
and actually were two ideas one is that
people will never do the right thing
unless the set of norms and I rules
Megan and the other here was that people
will not be Viking unless you aspiring
not command be honest or creative oh
good and the interesting idea that came
out over those two it actually spoke
it's great to be inspirational at great
to follow somebody thinkers inspiration
if you have to understand that in order
to make a change or a difference in the
world
have to somehow take this inspiration in
a really big human kind of a system in
which italian and then i thought was
very much thank you